what's going on everybody this week on
the real ones my guest is David air
David air is one of the greatest
American filmmakers of all time made
movies like End of Watch and uh Harsh
Times and fury wrote the movie Training
Day being in the movie Fury was one of
the greatest joys of my life a lot of
the folks that I brought on the show or
people that I've met through David in
this conversation Dave is
extraordinarily Brave courageous and
open I love this man I admire this man
this man's given me so much he's been
through a ton and he really opens up
here I'm again eternally grateful to
David for just so many reasons and I
love you boss thanks for coming on
all right
[Music]
bunch of cameras and [__] how does that
make you feel man with it with the
cameras cameras being on you confuses me
it does how so why because I'm on the
wrong side yeah yeah like I'm behind the
fourth wall you know what I mean yeah
yeah
when was the last time when was the last
time you did something like that where
you were on camera
like never huh media [__] like this
yeah yeah yeah let's repeat the same
thing 30 times in a row speed dating
format yeah yeah and then you get the
one journalist he's like I'm gonna craft
the question that if you answer honestly
will destroy your career and then I'm
gonna sit back and watch you answer it
right right but then you do media
training and then it's like just answer
the question you wish they asked yeah
and then they get that far away look in
their eye like the way they should be
treated like like literally ignore them
completely oh my God yeah
yeah everyone's trying to feed off
everybody now it's crazy man it's crazy
there's no one as far as like this thing
that we've been doing
you you've kind of been at the center so
much there's so many points of
connection on this show it's like kanejo
and Beau and Shia and Kev and Tyler it's
like they're all kind of you know you're
talked about a lot man and and and uh
you know I I I you know for me you you
know I got to see you know when I was a
kid there was a there was a football
coach in DC for the number eight Boys
Club police boys and girls club named
Buddy Burkett and Buddy Burkett was a
[__] Savage dude he was like a
[__] Savage there was once this real
big kiss big fat kid named Lamont and we
we used to call him lamonty and he had
behavior problems and Buddy Burkett like
made him do push-ups and sit-ups till
his kidneys [__] he had to go to the
hospital and he used to if you got in
trouble buddy Burkett would put like one
guy if you if you [__] around he'd put
you on one side of the field and put
everybody else on the field on the other
and he would basically be like go get
him you know and and I remember like
even into like my high school years even
though I didn't play for him or like you
know didn't see him since he since I was
like 11 if he was coaching on a field
like you would you would not go by that
field if Buddy brickett was there and it
would it would always put you back in
this place of uh of fear and and uh and
and just like unbelievable kind of uh
respect and uh in a way man like knowing
you were coming up today it it it it it
put me in this place of uh I was like
[__] man the the boss the boss is coming
and I remember I went to go do King
Richard Will Smith and the first thing
he [__] said is like he was like man
you've done you've done David Ayer movie
like you [__] with air and like you get
that look in his and look man I I when I
think about
um
not just all the points of connection
but but no you know the experience that
I had with you uh was like the defining
artistic experience of my life it was
like something I I you know it's just
kind of everything changed after that
for me not some [__] [__] like oh
I started getting more up just
everything changed for me how I view
this thing and and uh and when I think
about
like how like the the mental and and
physical and like emotional anguish that
we were put through and and when I think
about how we were like beaten down I saw
these like grown men like [__] movie
stars like crying and begging for you
know begging and and reduced down to the
way they were and it was such a um it
was such a brutal experience but now
when I look at it uh now when I look at
the whole thing looking back man it's
just like I I see how much [__] love
was there and how much you [__] cared
and not just being a vet but your
dedication to like who that story was
about and how you didn't give one of us
a [__] chance of not taking that so
[__] experience and then and and and
putting us you know you know you know
going to going to the bases being with
the guys getting to have to spend time
with like those gems of people who
actually experience what was like in
World War II there was no choice there
was no days off there's no [__] it
was like your foot was on our [__]
throat the whole time but but what's
crazy is like was like the most loved
I've ever felt by a director it was it
was the seminal kind of experience and
and uh so I you know I don't do like
[__] introductions man I'm like well
so today but uh I just wanted to say
that man and I also wanted to say like
do you do you still do you still work
like you just got off a movie do you
still work like that
it's
the world's changing big time and and
it's harder and
I think now for me it's like picking my
lane and picking my battles and picking
my opportunities you know and right now
I'm just happy to [__] work can I
cuss yeah you usually do whatever [__]
you want I told you literally [__] on
the table dude like with Fury
I don't know I think there's just
moments in life where things unfold
certain ways and and that unfolded all
these things came together
and things that shouldn't have come
together came together
just like getting a freaking
working Tiger tank on set you know
having an actual German tiger tank on
set instead of like oh it's a Volkswagen
covered with you know green screen or
something
um but like
the time I had everybody the way
everybody sense that something bigger
was happening
um with that project
and it just it was just kind of blessed
it just kind of unfolded you know and I
think that's always going to be like
that and then to watch are going to be
like my two
two to beat you know as far as a
director goes you you think you could
could Fury be made now
yeah but it would be twice as expensive
it would be a lot more money I want to
do another World War II movie and I'm
trying to figure out how how do I do it
how do I even do it you know
um
but it's it's a weird movie like it was
a weird movie because I had full control
it wasn't by committee it wasn't a bunch
of people telling me what to do
and it was it was just Vision it was
just like I was chasing something with
my heart you know and and then you guys
were like fully willing to dive in all
the way and the prep you guys did was
freaking it was stupid it was ridiculous
I mean bananas you guys were crewing
doing combined arms
the field exercises with a freaking
operating tank in infantry blasting off
Ordnance and blanks and stuff like that
like operating the machine
you know you guys kind of got to the
point where you became it and and it's
like how do you how do you even do that
how do you become something is
a soldier in war with everything that's
happening
and that's why I just kept putting you
guys through so much because I had to be
the War I had to be the source of stress
I had to be you know you think about
like what does a human being go through
in war and cortisol adrenaline and you
know stress hormones right you get
banged in your you know your lizard
brain who are you when you're
experiencing that stress you know and
you see each character in that tank
everybody had a different stress
reaction you know everybody reacted a
different way yeah and you know like
your character would kind of fall apart
and become very beta and very dependent
and like tell me what to do and I'll do
it I don't want to think for myself just
tell me what to do and I'll [__] die
for you if you tell me to go die I'll go
do that and I may her be hurt and
confused but I love you and I'm going to
do that because I trust you and that was
like that whole dynamic in the in that
tank it was a pressure cooker are you
like in in this film that you just did I
mean are you still having guys fight
each other and all that [__] I mean this
one was a little different because it's
like it's like a straight genre movie so
it's like how do I how do I take like a
really straightforward genre movie and
like elevate it and I just I just didn't
have the time you know it was like like
it's like money
in time are the big drivers in this and
then
it's it's it's hard because you need
access to the talent you need that
rehearsal time to build that energy and
you know
it's it's tough I tell people now you
all tell actors like yeah you think like
uh
you know De Niro was like double book
and scores AC and like researching two
pro projects at the same time when
they're working together right like that
sense of
rip your guts out and eat them kind of
dedication is is is absolutely
disappearing so I'm finding like
because you know me like I go I go hard
like like I want the road map of your
soul I want I want to know everything
about you I want to know your best mom I
want to know your worst moment I want to
know
because you're the actor right your body
is your instrument what what what does
it contain what does your body contain
what does your memory contain how are
you wired and
and I know you want to like
you know the Moscow Academy which is
like traditional
old school find the human pain and
explore it and now we're in a world
where nobody wants to be uncomfortable
yeah right and art comes from discomfort
art comes from uncertainty art comes
from Pain art comes from Agony and and
then just even like culturally now you
know like like who am I to push my ideas
into the culture at this point you know
do I have a voice do I have value as a
human being do I have value as a Creator
what stories am I allowed to tell what
stories am I not allowed to tell so it's
just like the world's changed so fast
and so much
and it's like if you can bring any kind
of truth I'm just chasing human truth
right
I'm just chasing human truth and they
have I call it the corporate map of the
human soul right which is like Hollywood
filmmaking the human soul is in this
little specific box that makes them
comfortable that they've defined
and with the [__] I've seen in life
that's right yeah dude like the hood the
street the military the this that the
chaos you know I know I have a much
better sense of
what a human being is
than some rich kid that went to an Ivy
League school and is now my boss at a
studio that works for a committee like
it is what it is right right and and you
like in you
I mean is there is there still World in
which guys like you get to do your thing
without that that [__] coming in
and and tainting it yeah I mean it's
like again it's pick your line pick your
battle you know and
you know the good healthy career diet is
like you know a couple for them one for
you you know
um but it's
my my canvas my paints my brushes cost a
ridiculous amount of money you know so
like in Suicide Squad there's like days
where shoot they you know six seven
hundred thousand dollars a day right
right or or even a small budget movie
you're looking at a burn rate of a
couple hundred grand a day right that's
a lot of money like it's millions of
dollars someone has to hand me millions
of dollars for me to do my work right
which means I gotta trust me they gotta
believe in me but they also have to
believe in the business plan you know so
it's like
the the business and the money have have
taken
everything over and
I'm lucky because I have a lot of
autonomy and control and I'm able to
like create an ecology where I can hunt
freely but that's disappearing man yeah
like like everything is just
being reduced to [__] nothing
what do you think like I mean is it the
pain man like I I just see this like
super strong connection like with you I
just I remember just responding to you
like [__] immediately like my my
first audition
for you like I was like man I'll do and
it wasn't just because like I loved and
to watch that my it's just like the way
the way that you were and the way you
just sized up the room and the way you
handle yourself like you you know what
do you think that is I mean is that
something you've always been able to do
get people to kind of like follow you
because again it's not normal to see
guys like you know like [__] Will
Smith or Brad or [__] like that to be
like hey dude like I'll go to this
[__] boot camp like I won't sleep for
[__] three weeks I'll [__] in the
ammo can like I'll I'll have guys like
call me maggot and [__] it but you know
what I mean it's like one thing like I'm
like dude whatever I don't give a [__]
but like those guys to to to to follow
that Holy and to make a movie as if it's
you had us all convinced make this movie
like it's the last one you'll ever make
and if you think about like what that
movie's about who that movie's for it's
[__] worth it like it like we really
were like dude we'll we'll give you
whatever have you always had that
through life
man that's a crazy question that's a
hard question I mean I've always been an
outsider big time and I've always found
myself in like really [__] up extreme
circumstances where I had no choice but
to figure out how to survive from zero
from zero from Day Zero I never had like
family and safety and love and all that
[__] that people talk about like that's
not my experience and so
like
I had to get really really really good
at reading energy and reading the room
and reading people and and being like
super strategic about oh that person can
be an ally that person is going to be an
enemy I got to watch out for them like
like what do I have to do to eat tonight
what do I have to say to eat tonight and
so I became like
I get hyper Vigilant in the human
behavior space you know and
I'm also fascinated by people and it's
like a love-hate thing like I love the
human spirit I love what we're capable
of and what we've achieved is Humanity
but I hate a lot of the stupid [__] we
do to each other and I don't know I mean
I started I started writing and then
it's like you create something then you
hand it over to these parents that raise
it up and it's like they're abusive
parents and they [__] your kid up and
that's not what I wanted so I wanted to
direct and I don't know man it's like
like I just know how people are wired
and for me it's like respect like like I
don't disrespect people like I won't
disrespect you as an actor a human being
will [__] hurt you I'll make you hurt
yourself I'll make you find pain I'll
make you find love I'll make you find
things that you didn't know and had you
had inside of yourself but I'll never
disrespect the contents of your soul you
know and I think that's like one of the
reasons I survived so well where I have
and all these [__] up environments is
because I never judged or just I don't
judge people I don't disrespect people
and every human being is a universe
every human being has a world inside of
them and a story and value and truth and
if you can find that and I can connect
with that and help you connect with that
and then create an environment where
it's safe for you to pull these things
out of yourself and show people like
that's art that's that's what it is
right there and this unbelievable like
exploration that you get people like
I've been on that [__] Journey with
you you feel like you you feel like
you've done that with yourself you feel
like you you you I have lately like like
my life has been
it's crazy you know like
like my life is a [__] show it's like
it's a [__] tornado and and I just
call it the vortex and it's like my dad
killed himself you know when I was like
four years old Christmas day in the
[__] house you know Merry Christmas
like and then [__] got nuts after that
you know and and so
like this life I have you know that's
[__] passed around I think I live
like 12 different places before I was 12
years old like like like in [__]
abuse and and horrific [__] and and
neglect like you name it over the top
[__] right and
then I oh I can write I have this this
this this way I can express myself
um
but uh
you know then then Hollywood happened
and you know I'd like this this super
traditional marriage and kids you know
for a long time and that was how I
identified myself and then suddenly like
oh I'm an A-list director
and I started to identify with that and
then like like covet hit everything hit
all culture stuff hit
um Hollywood kind of shut down you know
the culture was reassessing like like
people's positions and everything
and
all the noise was taken away and then I
was alone and then the marriage ended
you know and so like everything I
identified myself with disappeared so
now I'm just like who am I you know and
honestly now it's like I ain't [__] you
know and it's like like
I don't like getting compliments I don't
like people being so you know effusive
about my work and stuff like that
because I don't identify myself with
that now you know I did before and I
kind of needed that and that ego armor
yeah and now it's just like like I just
want to pay my [__] bills man would
you describe that feeling as freeing is
it scary like how would you describe
that feeling of like letting go of all
that [__]
terrifying and then freeing and then
terrifying
um but then the question is who who am I
like what am I what am I it's like
really the biggest question you know and
and what kind of human being am I um so
like I know I'm a Storyteller I know I
can change lives like
um good friend of mine Sean who's like
like in Dev group
was like downrange and and got lit up
really bad I think shot like six or
seven times right [__] thrashed he
was basically done and
depressed lost lost his best friend and
the same incident and you know told me
about how during rehab he's in a
wheelchair they took him to see Fury
and he's sitting there in the wheelchair
and in Fury something happened when he
was watching that
that was the moment he defined as the
beginning of his road to recovery and
now the dude's like you know he got back
in the dub went you know back active
duty downrange all that stuff
um throw up plates lift weights all that
but like some human decision something
inside of him decided to come back from
the dark place that he he was in and he
fully attributes that to that
collaborative creation that is Fury and
I hear stuff like that
and it's it's like humbling like what
you know and that's what I'm learning to
respect and what I have to respect is
there is something larger that can move
through me
but because your instinct is to push
that [__] away or to like not feel I
mean I think we're alike that way I
don't want to hear you know you know it
doesn't mean I'm like I suck I you know
I I I remember after one take on Fury
coming back to you and being like I'm
quitting dude I'm like leaving this
whole foot you're like go quit that's
all you said you just said don't quit
and that was like the you know I was
like all right [__] it you know because
I just [__] hate myself so much
you know obviously you know like part of
the process you you know especially in
that movie was like you know talking
about what happened with your dad and
all and and and and kind of going
forward and then you know our own
relationship to you know Brad's
character and all that but it's just
like there you know I know you hate the
[__] compliments man but that you
know that script is just like the
[__] greatest thing ever written dude
and everybody who read it said that and
it just
you know man like can you can you just
talk a little bit about like your family
and your upbringing and and and and I
know I I you know and if you can't you
can't but like you know I I know you
spent some time and it's sort of where
near where I grew up and and uh and you
and I'm just really curious about how
you like found your way to California
which had such an imprint on you
it's nuts um I mean my family's from
California originally like my mom went
to UCLA and all that stuff
um but like it my life makes no [__]
sense so like I guess you know my dad
was like a geologist and my mom was like
an academic studying psychology
um
in
you know he he passed interesting thing
like he lost his reputation his career
his woman like his life was
systematically destroyed to the point
where he just couldn't take it he was
like a rock star in the geological field
and then got convinced to take over a
project outside of his like expertise
and then
bunch of corrupt ass [__] was going on
really like this is Mexico you know and
I'm like like my family lived in Mexico
in the beginning and
like it's just makes no sense they ended
up like fleeing the country with the
clothes on their back you know
um this is all this fraud and [__]
happening like it's like deep stuff you
know I've seen these patterns in my life
these Echoes watching like institutional
failures and how they destroy people and
Destroy families and all that like
but yeah I ended up in foster care
[Applause]
um you know it was [__] up and then uh
you know like my mom is a deep cat
smartest person I know yeah um but just
like you know been married a bunch of
times like not a mother in the classic
sense of the word like not like [__]
hug you but like here's some Soul Poison
that may fuel you as an adult you know
thanks mom
um but
I don't even know how to explain it uh
with what went down with your dad though
I mean like to do it kind of how he did
it or when he did it forgive me but
there's some sort of like Showmanship
there's some sort of like he made a
point there and oh yeah and whatever
that was no he he wrote like a 12-page
suicide note made copies and hit him all
over the [__] house including tape
tape one under the toilet tank right I
never saw the note I never saw what he
got to set which is really frustrating
you know and everyone I later in life I
reached out and met people that knew him
everyone loved this guy like love this
guy you know and but he just got
destroyed
by a system and by a woman and and I
took like a lot of lessons from that of
like I'm gonna understand how [__]
power it works I understand how the
system works I understand how people
work
um it really put me in the defensive in
a big way
but did that start early on I mean yeah
had to like I was a foster care man I'm
like like I was I was always
like the spare body in the corner you
know that like somebody legally has to
feed I guess because if I die they'll
get in trouble but that was kind of like
my childhood do you remember your first
feelings like having to leave home and
like going into somebody else is that do
you remember oh yeah I remember all of
it like what did I feel like very
conscious I don't know how to explain it
but I was always like stoic as [__] it
was almost like like I was born and it's
like like this [__] is gonna be a
[__] and it's gonna get bad and
worse and somehow I had that knowledge
as a kid you know and I knew that like
my lot in life wasn't going to be like
other people I wasn't going to get like
the love and the family and all this
other [__] which I try to create later
in life but yeah I would just like my
mom was a piece of work she was like an
entrepreneur she was like like really
Progressive for the Times
um also like super connected like she
knew like her her dad was like a colonel
and and Military I come from a military
family and so she always knew how to
manipulate like the government side and
get in in that world and you know show
me a bit of that
um
she's wild I guess she's like in Vegas
she used to work at the casino like as a
show like a beautiful woman beautiful
[__] woman yeah like like and I've
just heard absolutely insane [__] about
her
but not a mother by any means and did
you guys stay kind of connected through
jumping around from house to house and
Foster Care would you go back with her
for I ended up ended up back with her
and you know she got remarried and he
was gonna say the guy was like super
[__] abusive like the first like I'm
just gonna say it like the first time I
had an older sister was like nine he
kind of took care of me until she
punched out and arranged like living
arrangements for herself right
first time he met her she was 14 he
knocked her out just [__] knocked her
out like like boom you saw it no no but
uh it's it's just like like that's
how people were treated as I was growing
up you know and and so it's like you're
not safe yeah these adults that are
[__] psychotic and violent right so
it's I've always been around violence
I've always seen it um
and then
but like with my mom we ended up like we
moved all over the place
you know Florida Maryland [__]
Minnesota
um but yeah I ended up in Maryland on
the East Coast
and I really started getting in trouble
um because I was like running the
streets and going into DC and you know
going like Shady Grove and underground
parties and just like like I was a wild
kid I was like young as [__] too like 13
14. yeah and then I caught a case
um and my mom was broke like we never
had money right so that's the only thing
I never had money growing up like so
like she couldn't feed me I was doing
scams to eat right you know little
crimes and [__] like that and
you know finally it was like I had to
get out of there you know like like
there's some real negative [__] going on
that she was trying to push me towards
you know like dark yeah what the [__]
yeah and somehow I have like this
survival mechanism where I always know I
want to get out I want to go I want to
bail and so I got out
Kim came to LA because my cousins lived
there
um when I said a California family so
came up came back and uh
that was like from minor league
criminality to like graduate level like
because I mean where'd you wind up like
where [__] West Adams South Central
um and this is the 80s so it's like
you know when you come in speaking
Spanish like you no not really no
um I've always been really good with
[__] language and [__] like that but
like coming to South Central
I'm like the only white boy I'm in
um only white boy in my hood and
this is like
I mean that's I guess where I really
became who I am you know like and so
the basic survival patterns sort of
congealed into like a sense of identity
you know that's the thing like I don't
know who the [__] I am like like I don't
know who I am anymore you know and I
think about these things that I
experienced as a kid or what I went
through
and it's like it's like unreal right
but it's also normal because it's what I
lived and then I talk to people about it
and start comparing notes or you talk to
like civilians right like normal people
and they're just like oh [__] yeah you
know
um
like
it's like a dream it doesn't make sense
but like this this like [__] fluency
in in like violence and and pain and
like understanding and also
understanding you were one of the people
who really taught me that there's also
like a real Beauty there's a [__]
honesty in it yeah violence there's just
like and and somebody who you know dealt
with [__] on my own in my own life like
how to kind of like take that and
channel it and then put it into what we
do is like kind of everything and and
that's really changed my life in a big
[__] way the way that you you for me
it was always like run away from it like
don't let people really know and you
were like no dude like dive in like dig
into that [__] moon like go in there
and I wanna you didn't give like if you
were down to take the ride with you like
you [__] dude and and uh you have so
much love for for Los Angeles and you
have like I remember one time and you
just say these things it just stuck with
me so much but I remember one time I
think we're on like some [__] press
tour some [__] and you were just
like I mean we're in like some Hotel you
know we're like it's some hotel that I
mean it's just like you get tea in a
[__] cup that like you know it's like
a [__] car and it's like you know
Butler's wiping your ass and [__] and
you're like yeah I was like so what are
you gonna do next you're just like I
just got to get back to the streets man
figure out the [__] is going on and I
was like that's exactly right man like
it so like what what did you find in La
that you really responded to be Beyond
like the chaos like what what kind of
love did you because I know you made
like lifelong relationships there and
you found like a family in the streets
it was family it was like
like
all the [__] that made me weird
or would make people uncomfortable about
me
in regular life became like a superpower
in the street right how so
um being able to hang being able to like
like the streets are [__] meritocracy
right I don't care who you say you are
that's right they're gonna break you
down and show you who you are real fast
right
and
you know I'm hanging out with these
people it's funny like I'm 15 years old
and I'm in in this club called The Press
Club which doesn't exist anymore because
they put the uh
Convention Center that tore it down and
put the convention center there like on
Pico and and so like pico like Pico and
Olympic was like crazy back in the day
it was like 18th Street controlled it
and they ran prostitution out of there
and you go by the hotels and you see all
the homies and the hyenas and everything
and it was just crazy
and so we'd go over there and drink go
to this place I'm 15 years old I'm
sitting in a strip club drinking beer
with the homies and it never occurred to
me like why is why am I being served at
15 in a [__] strip club you know or
I'd go to a neighborhood restaurant
and like the owners are like bending
over backwards to give you a [__]
drink right and I just it's like like I
was kind of like I never put it together
of like what's really happening here but
like you start to
go through these situations and it's
like oh it's the LAPD here comes a
[__] cops pajamas right
what happens if you [__] press the
cops
right so like you know normal civilian
world you don't do that or you know
right but on the streets it's like all
right two cops six of us every one of
these [__] will fight yeah some
dudes may have things that that are
worth fighting for that they don't want
the cops to have you know
how does this unfold now you know what's
the [__] psychology here you know and
then you see that moment where you see
like the fear and the cop size and it's
like oh we got this got him yeah
[__] yeah you know like and you start to
Savor these encounters you know and
and it was just like I was like
Crazy Dave crave
right that was like my name crave
because I was [__] crazy and and
there's always like the crazy guy and I
guess that was me like you guys have
that reputation and and plus I was just
in a stupid [__] like
there's a lot going on you know like a
lot of weapons a lot of death a lot of
power
um
you know and I saw the transition from
like crack when when freebasing like
people to freebase right
and it's like yeah the alcohol and the
[__] clip and the cotton swab and
that's how people were doing it right
for a minute and then I remember when
crack hit and totally different it was
like like oh [__] microwave baking still
a [__] rock it up
overnight it changed everything and one
of the first crack houses in La was like
on my block like on my [__] block
right and it's like
they would come through it was like like
my neighborhood was like rolling 20s
Bloods and and so like I had the Freeway
Rick connection all that [__] so there's
like kilos coming into my [__]
neighborhood and the key was like 14k
and everyone was just trying to get 14
Grand together because you could flip it
for 60. straight up yeah [__] it was
like
in the neighborhood started out like we
would play football with other
neighborhoods and and so like we came up
with like like marasabat Russia like I
used to hang out with Ms yeah like but
there were like Stoners back in the day
yeah like [__] long hair and would
wear like AC DC shirts and jeans and
Chucks like it was such a different vibe
but because I was close to MacArthur
Park where they all started and I was
like a house painter right so I was
always working with them and working
with people and in this world
and then the violence hit
and I just want like Cartoon Level
violence overnight
and the streets flipped from like it was
like the old heads and you know like
guys that played football in high school
and just like [__] like that just
suddenly like The Killers ran it right
so my neighborhood it was some kid was
like [__] 15 or something and and
suddenly he was the guy because he was
just killing everybody down for it
killing [__] everybody and and and
that's that violence piece and that
language of violence so it's like okay
so if you can just [__] kill people
and you don't have that conscious thing
going on oh you're gonna run the [__]
back you know what's that look like for
you for you at that point you you had
been around you'd seen all kinds of odds
you've seen probably one of the most
violent acts you could with your pops
you've seen that but what about your own
sort of like bursting through the bubble
of perpetrating it yourself and getting
your hands dirty I mean what was your
relationship with that and was that hard
for you because I I we talk about a lot
on here just like how a lot of that
starts I know for me it started a lot in
like fear and shame like God punks you
get your ass beat you get dumped or
something and then you're like you sit
there and like at night you're like [__]
I should have done this or [__] I should
have done that and then you do it but
then you start breaking through that
membrane you start perpetrating yourself
and then you kind of become the monster
a little bit you become that guy yeah
did you have a similar Journey
do you remember like one of your first
sort of like
real encounters with violence that you
had to perpetrate
yeah it was it's
it was a hash it was a hat like when I
was 17
got shot across the street from me my
house and like I don't know I was
feeling a Good Samaritan or something
and I like [__] gave him CPR you know
the dude like died I was like 17. the
dude [__] threw up all over me and
was throwing up blood clots and [__] and
I was like watch this guy die man it's
just like okay did you know him no no he
was from East L.A like our issue was
like like South Central and East L.A
were like [__] yeah like and this is
a different world then I was like where
are you from only from nowhere [__] you
boom like
my data girls in East LA too you know
they're like taking the bus there as
well like [__] a date of this black
girl in South Central like Compton and I
was taking like the Vermont line at
[__] midnight to go hang out with her
and stuff like I didn't give a [__] like
I went everywhere
um
yeah it's
it's hard like like because it doesn't
make a lot of sense to me and I see
things and I'm like like for me it's
just memories right so like
walk into Vermont to go to work and like
there's this bar in my neighborhood Mr
X's bar which is like where all the
homies would hang out and in front of Mr
X's like this [__] blood just all
over the sidewalk and blood clots and
[__] just like nasty yellow [__]
clots and
I'm like I gotta go to work I'm just
stepping over the blood like nothing you
know and that was like normal that was
like a normal thing like like gunfire
holy [__] every night there's gunshots
but not like [__] oh someone shot a
gun but like
boom boom boom fights like like yeah gun
fighting every night it wasn't it was
normal like it's crazy what becomes
normal that it's crazy yeah yeah yeah
and and at that point like when did you
meet uh Richard like when was it all in
that in that period no it's a little bit
after like high school world was a [__]
show I dropped out
um I was on L.A County Probation all
through high school so like I had to
take the bus down to crenshawn
Exposition and I'd like the gang lady po
yeah so she was like all harsh on me and
I don't know why I had the gang lady po
because I was very innocent and didn't
do [__] and it was like
like
like only white boy in the [__] boss
RTD back then she was like 50 cents or
something you know I know it's just like
to be able to fit into that environment
and be comfortable and navigate it and
not get pressed like
yeah just to learn that energy can you
just like can you can you describe it a
little bit like can you uh
I mean I I I really feel like I
understand what you're saying and I and
and being in in those in those
situations
um it never really ends right like it's
not like it's like from place to place
it's not like you can be like oh I don't
need to deal with this anymore it's like
it's a constant it's a constant constant
navigation like
um it's like an energy thing either you
belong or you don't either you're
comfortable or you're not and like
growing up
there's always like people of color
adopting me like like black families
Mexican families took me and fed me took
care of me you know so it's very
comfortable in those spaces and probably
not as comfortable with white folks no
which is crazy like like I remember boot
camp
um I was looking around look at all
these [__] white people like what the
hell is happening who are you well what
spaces are you comfortable being in you
know and then and then like I just
really a voice connected
with like heavy people like [__]
Killers like I'm moving through it
people have been through it what what
why why the military what like how did
that come about
uh like my grandfather retired officer
other grandfather retired officer you
know one's Army women's Navy submarines
um I've always been drawn to that
um world
you know through family stuff but like
growing up in high school I'm like
maybe I graduate maybe I don't I didn't
but I'll join the military and I'll get
[__] killed and I'll die young and
problem solved right like I never
thought I would live I never thought I
would live really past 18. so you know
like that was kind of my mindset
um
and then yeah I got in it and I did
really well and then I kind of got my
heart broken so
that was too idealistic I was looking
for the perfect home and I found it for
a second
um and it was like very different world
Cold War World very intense you know I
was on a nuclear submarine
um different culture back then you know
and
like there's a lot I won't say
uh
but it was
[__] up like it put me in some
dilemmas you know and and
you know I thought I was going to do it
my whole life and end up getting out
like how did you go I mean we we talked
a lot obviously making a movie about
like going through [__] war in a tin
box and like the the similarities to
summary like why that like why why do
you think you were drawn for that how
what's the process like to become to go
towards a submarine like what's that
training like like what what can you
tell us about that I mean
um
it's intense
well it's it's a weird job because
you're locked in a tube and everything
can kill you and it's a nuclear reactor
and
you know tons of explosives and you know
like a hydraulic header 3000 psi
hydraulic header if it blows a leak
it'll and you walk past it if it blows a
leak it'll instantly fill the submarine
with a high explosive gas mixture
right like and then the submarine can
explode from a spark like like
everything can kill you every you're
always on alert you're always in danger
I just like that I like that was that
common among guys who who flock towards
that yeah it's a volunteer you got a
double volunteer like in sub school they
put you in a steel tube light a fire put
you in firefighter gear and turnouts and
everything and it's like smoke you can't
see [__] and so if you can't handle that
then you probably don't want to be in a
submarine so they do things to kind of
make sure you know but like what do you
remember the first time like what was
the first thing was like yeah I want to
be in a [__] tube underwater like why
like was it just like that's dangerous
as [__] I want to go there was it like
just drawn to it like like you know my
grandfather did it all through World War
II you know but it's just
and and it was also kind of like
um real you know so you can join the
military and end up with a lot of
[__] jobs like oh we're cruising
around the Indian Ocean on
you know an auxiliary exciting
um like the [__] we we did we were in it
we were in it and I got to see like how
the world Works firsthand got to see
like the game got to see and it's funny
coming to it with a street kind of
mindset yeah and then then you see like
oh [__] this is just big homie [__] no
and they're just just pressing and
peeping and and you know
ready to throw down if they have to so
it was just like seeing
politics work on a larger scale scale
like the the the culture of violence and
use of violence and management of
violence and threat of violence
nation-state level and and like do do
you have like art at this point in your
life like any like artistic aspirations
or like did you write did you like
[__] Journal like were you were you
an Avid Reader oh it's red always red
always read a lot a lot a lot that was
always my escape and then
um I could always write so like in high
school I'd like write one thing in the
beginning of the year and they'd leave
me alone and give me my C you know and
and then in the Navy I started I didn't
think that that's just was natural
god-given talent and and and creative or
just like essays or name it yeah name it
did you ever write creatively for
yourself or for other people minimally
and then like I did the Navy I started
journaling
um there's there's a lot to process like
it's so funny because like like now in
hindsight it's like yeah I went through
the ringer I had so much [__] I was
trying to process and didn't even know
how and didn't even know was abnormal
yeah
um but
you know it was once I got out that I
really started writing like almost
immediately I wrote my first script the
second I got out like on a typewriter
damn I'm always ask great that was about
the Navy
it was shitty but it got me meetings
so so so and why you were in were you
like I'm gonna make a movie about this
no or you're like I'm gonna write a
movie about this or no no but like why
why a script you were just like I mean
when did that aspiration well I mean I
had a roommate
uh who's like trying to be a
screenwriter and and was also like grown
up in La there's always like like oh
Hollywood you know can you make it in
Hollywood and stuff like this weird
industry over there you can make money
if you can get into that um but I I was
an electrician after I got out I wired
this guy's house up um this guy was a
screenwriter Wesley strick and told him
C stories and he's like
write a script
and I ended up living in this guy's
house and wrote my first script
you know and I just kept at it I kept at
it it kept getting rejected and then
finally I wrote training day you know
like
and I mean were you aware of the
uniqueness of your perspective no it's a
shame to the ashamed of it yeah because
there's no one I could share it with
like you know a lot of my life for a lot
of my personality I could really only be
myself around like homies you know
people from the hood
um
you know as always feel that way
I feel when I'm hanging out in those
spaces I feel very at home
I feel very at home yeah and it was so
funny because like
I was like trying to be the white boy
for Hollywood for so long and I'd go to
these meetings and it's like oh [__] how
do I dress what do I say you know like
I'm gonna talk different
um
like I was trying to be like them you
know what a [__] it was like it's
what a [__] dumb dumb idea it never
works that's what I've learned it's like
authenticity you know and can you be
around people that see you and can you
allow yourself to be seen you know
um it's
that's deep dude so I mean like I've
heard you can you just tell the the
story about uh about training day and
first of all like how that story came to
you and then what that's like and where
you were when you found out that I sold
and all that [__] I mean I I had been
writing scripts
um
nothing had really sold and I kept
getting rejected and I was right you
think you were good
I knew I was as good as stuff that was
selling yep so I would read [__] and be
like I can do that yeah
um
but I I was getting these projects
rejected and so I decided to write like
something I knew they would reject so I
could be free free to write it instead
of like I'm gonna write into this box I
think you'll buy I was like I'm just
going to tell a story and you know I
wrote it I started writing it in like 95
or 96 right and this is like five six
years before Rampart and because I was
hanging out in the streets and I lived
at Echo Park at the time
and I was always like in it I was always
in South Central as always in the hood
like just in it in it and looking for
trouble and you know you're hanging out
and you start hearing the stories and
you hear the same stories and it's like
ours is crew of LAPD and they're jacking
people and this and that and the truth
of it
so much beyond what anybody knows like
like the department did such an amazing
job of like like a magic trick it's
really about this when it was just like
the Beast it's just the Beast they're
smashing dude and the [__] they're up to
you [__] cop car police uniform
police radio
no no you're gonna go smashing the
homies doing your own thing you know now
you're a Transformer right which on the
streets is the best thing right like I
was a Transformer I was like a
Decepticon I am a white boy
but it it they yeah and I just kept
hearing these stories
so you know I just started writing it
down and and creating finding the truth
around that and then I based on
you know Denzel's character on my
homie's dad on Richard's dad that's
basically Richard's dad right who's like
this retired medically retired Marine
Vietnam vet
um but like super high power Street guy
with like just Street analogy like that
pimpnosis you know like like a really
good Street guy
has an ability to almost create a magic
field around them and get you believing
anything you know in the way they talk
and the tales and they understand like
[__] you know tap you on the knee
when they're talking and get that
hypnotic thing going you know and like
this guy was all that man he was he was
like
he told like it was a [__] up story
but he talked a guy into like killing
himself
like he just got on this one dude's head
so bad that that the guy ran into the
bathroom pulled his watch off and tried
to cut his wrist like like that's the
like psychology and the power of
psychology in that dark Street
psychology when you understand that [__]
yeah and you're able to play with it
yeah
man God bless and so like I just threw
that character into that Arena
wrote the script nobody bought it
so that's not how cops are
and the whole police genre was dead like
cheesy cheesy cop movies they're just
dead like what is it what's it what are
cop movies at that time yeah they're
just like it's like really bad yeah
really solos and
yeah I mean it's funny because that
script became my calling card script and
got me work it was originally
you know different director there's
going to be a Matt Damon Sam Jackson
version like like it just goes through
all these iterations you know and then
um
you know Denzel jumped on it to his
credit
and then um you know the producer was
like
do an option you know or they give you
so much money against the sale price
right and I told them and I was I didn't
have a refrigerator I didn't have a
mattress you know to live in an Echo
Park like you were living with Richard
no no no I was alone at the time like
when when this went down and then um
like I don't want an option
if you don't trust me on my handshake
you don't want to be in business with me
another smartest move I did because I
ended up selling it for like a million
dollars yeah you know and
and ended up getting made
when you get when you get that news I
mean what is that
what is that what is that like for you
it's not real yeah you know like like
I remember like I used to be poor man
you know I told you to grow poor like I
know hunger I grew up hungry I know what
that is and
and then like when I was like starving
artist like I remember one time I bought
[__] jars of spaghetti sauce and I'm
coming home from the store and the bag
ripped and they both broke and I I
almost cried I'm sitting there looking
at my spaghetti sauce on the sidewalk
like almost in freaking tears because
that was my money I had no money dude
like like man
and when I started getting money writing
and stuff I just would have the check
sitting there
like a 350 000 checks just stacked on my
TV because I didn't know what to do with
them right and like a deposit one in the
bank and then all sudden the bank's like
calling me this guy's all calling me
nice from the bank right
what is this you know like there's this
whole new world when you have money who
knew right and then like I got an
accountant and he's like so
you know you haven't filed tax returns
for the past seven years
old
I'll need the man up in my business
straight up just sitting on my TV bro
yeah for me that's always like the
watermark like like like if you have a
period of life where you ain't been
filing taxes
we good yeah yeah
it's all good but it's just this world
you know this whole new world opened up
to me
um yeah it was schizophrenic because
like I'd be in the streets I'd be in
Hollywood I'd be doing this doing that
and then trying to pretend I'm not doing
nothing so
what what do you think like I mean
through that time of bouncing back and
forth at some point you get the bug of
being like I want to make this [__]
myself but but uh I mean what was the
experience I mean was was there any like
big Purpose with like what what you
wanted out of your art or the
possibilities that you saw not like
Financial possibilities but to be able
to tell certain stories it's the
corporate map of the human soul man it's
like the disconnect because like I'd
seen all this [__] happen with human
beings and I had a personal
understanding the lived experience of of
of of what people are right and I felt
like my version
was more profound because I can I'm I'm
comfortable looking at the whole animal
I'm comfortable with the darkness and
comfortable with the light if the light
you know comes out of incredible
darkness and pain and Agony isn't it
that much brighter you know
and you I feel like everyone's trying to
diminish what we are and what we're
capable of you know and it's like like
kill spirituality kill the spirit turn
us into just atomized tribalized
hateful [__] atoms fragments that's
what humanity is being turned into and
and for me it's like I've seen
Miracles I've seen human Miracles I've
seen the human heart I've seen power
I've seen death I've seen life I've seen
birth like there's so much in Us and
nobody wants to talk about that anymore
you know and
and it's like like with training day it
was kind of simple it was like
what happens when you put the devil
and an angel in a cop car was kind of
the basic idea and then the real thesis
I was kind of answering was in a corrupt
world what happens when one man says no
you know and it's like
the big moment in Training Day
that like if you're really [__] hood
and you live that life you may see it
but
Denzel is like a thousand miles ahead of
this guy all day long right for the most
part of Ethan and then
later on towards the end of it
you know they're talking and then he
finds out that Ethan's parents were
[__] heroin addicts right which means
he was on game as a kid saw that whole
life and had this whole level of
understanding
that Alonso didn't know he had he didn't
see it coming he didn't see a commas
right yeah and that's how this kid was
able to [__] in outmaneuver him because
he just that point in people's lives
where you have the power you have the
control you get [__] lazy and you
stop seeing the person in front of you
so this dude who had all this commanding
power over the whole world couldn't see
the person sitting next to him and that
brought him down yeah yeah basic what
was that I mean what was that like to
see that [__] thing get made then I
mean were you like did you have did you
did you like it like did you did you
have an opinion on it yeah it was a trip
dude it was like um I was a co-producer
on it and I was
I was there like I was just I was wild
at the time and and my problem is I
didn't really understand how to
interface with Hollywood
you know and and like people saw me as
[__] wild yeah that's like black eyes
dude that show up to set with like two
black eyes from the weekend you know
from getting into God knows what yeah
like like I was wild and
and
me and Bone went
and uh uh you know
went to Athens Park sat down met with
the big homie
and it was like hey this is what we want
to do
can we shoot here like no one had ever
done that no one had ever filmed in
these neighborhoods you know and so we
went went to all the shock haulers and
all the different hoods getting
permission you know and it's like okay
cool hey
extra meals at catering I need you to
hire this many homies the security you
know put this dude in the movie like
like you kind of negotiate it we want to
know who the cops are on set you know
um
you know we just we just need to know
who's where and what's going on and how
we do our business and and and because
you knew that you needed to make a
certain kind of film in a certain kind
of way telling a certain kind of Truth
cheesy otherwise you know like some
[__] actors the other big gang movie
was like colors and and colors like gets
the cop stuff right but the gang stuff
feels cheesy you know and it's it's that
thing where it's hard to explain like
when you're in the streets or you know
you're like you could see someone and
read their energy right and oh that
dude's a [__] player all right and
and then you watch a movie and it's like
they don't have the gravitas they don't
know the reality of it and you can't
fake that energy it was it was it was a
wild time
um
yeah it was a trip like there you know
and then sometimes there'd be politics
and then you get sucked into that and
you're trying to clean that up and like
we're shooting over here and you know
because like like the Hollywood people
like gun comes out someone starts
blasting everyone [__] freaks out
right right but it's but like you know
you you
to to the same extent that that you're
so committed to to the vets in World War
I mean it's like yeah man it's like if
we're gonna make this we're gonna ask
permission we're gonna do it with
respect we're gonna tell the truth we're
gonna like we're gonna bring them in
that sacred move what's what are the
human stories you know so it's like
like am I a thief am I stealing stories
am I taking stories that aren't mine to
tell like like what what do we share
what do we not share what what's my
responsibility
you know so like
if I'm making a movie about Hoodrats
[__] yeah I gotta get in there and I
gotta talk to people you know I got to
be respectful and and you know at the
end of the day
like
even if you're a street guy right you
have a hierarchy you you connected to an
organization it is what it is there's
rules it's worse than the military yeah
you know God forbid you lose money
you know
um
you get caught up in the politics like
amen no I know you got the kid and
you've been with your lady now but we
got to go handle this thing
oh [__] is that the end of my life as I
know it you know and and people are in
these lives and and
you know I got like like relatives in
prison people you know I know people in
prison get caught up in the life you get
the case and that's it and that's Murder
She Wrote and they're not props they're
not
tools to be used they're not something
to extract value from right you know
right um
so if I'm telling your story as a matter
of respect I got to get it right man
yeah yeah like and and like compare that
just like that that that that inherent
that inherent thing that you that you
that's just part of you and there's no
[__] Choice like you you're doing it
that way but now you're in a world
that's all about sort of like the Optics
of that now you're in a world that's all
about like you know dotting the eyes
okay so now oh okay now we're doing
rehearsals and and I have actors with me
and you know we start getting happy and
talking about your past and this and
that and then you know what if someone
feels like I've encroached on a boundary
right and then now they're uncomfortable
and now it's like okay so and then
especially now where it's like I'm a
white boy man I'm like I'm the [__]
toxic residue of History man I'm like
I'm like the progenitor of evil in the
world man like like and that's what
people see when they see my skin you
know and it's such a trip because I grew
up is like like the only white boy right
and and like people color spaces right
right and and I you catch [__] for it at
first and then it's like yeah whatever
all right you're [__] you're like the
rest of us cool you know and then and
then now it's like okay what
what does that mean what what are my
responsibilities you know what are my
responsibilities as a Storyteller in
this culture you know and again it gets
what am I allowed to say what am I not
allowed to say because there sure should
have been plenty of [__] people who
did look at these folks as as [__]
props to extract their stories hey we're
telling us to portray you never have a
conversation never be in someone's house
never be in their churches in there
right it's like but you but how does it
feel being somebody who just did that
[__] naturally not like on your soapbox
hey look how great I am you just
wouldn't do it any other [__] way
because you give a [__] you care about
your art I wouldn't know how to do it
like like I know the space is
uncomfortable in and I like to be those
spaces and I like to share those spaces
so like the first movie I directed was
like Harsh Times with Christian Bale and
um
and so like I took them around to the
neighborhoods and how to meet people and
how to meet homies and how to meet like
different like families you know you
know like oh what's it like to sit down
with a family and have dinner in East
L.A you know like what's that Vibe like
what's a table conversation
um I had to meet like
dudes that he would have grown up with
like like us [__] you know Vietnam
veteran you know who's super big into
like um
you know the recovery piece and PTSD at
The Cutting Edge of it and you could
talk all that stuff you know and you
hear his stories and it's like like this
is someone you would have grown up with
and someone who whose energy you would
have wanted to match you know and and so
like for actors a lot of what I do is
getting them in the real spaces so they
can see the behavior and scan it you
know because I know I know you guys are
like little Xerox machines you're
[__] watching everything man like
we're some kids you know it's like
[__] you see everything so if I can
put you in these spaces and you can feel
that energy in that human connection
that's priceless man but you can do your
job better you know and and did you know
Christian like did you know he I mean
he's like built for that [__] like like
and you did you know that off the Jump
is that why you wanted him but I mean a
big part of it I imagine too is having
Christian around you and seeing the way
you roll and the way you live in the
hood and how you handle yourself being
around richer I mean because isn't like
blue and like all those guys are in the
movies and
uh like clearly you can [__] write
you write like this [__] amazing
[__] thing what makes you say hey I
can go make this movie and then like you
like Leverage your house on it like
making the decisions I did a music video
first saw these homies with a band and
I'm like okay I'm gonna pay to do a
music video I'm gonna see what it's like
to control a set even if I Vibe it at
all but why did you want what was it
what what was the first like what a lot
of us training just seeing training day
and in the process and how it unfolded
and seeing the department heads and
seeing what exactly a director does was
there things that you thought didn't
work or what could have worked better or
was there things where you were like I
could [__] do or I could bring
something not to [__] on that because
it's a masterpiece but like right but
it's like was there anything you were
like [__] dude my style you always see
it as a writer like someone who created
that you always see it a bit different
you know so it was different and I love
the vision and I love what the movie
became and it had to become that but
part of me was like all right I want to
do this I want to do this okay which was
crazy because you know I didn't
it's a high school dropout man like like
um and so I wrote
Harsh Times actually I wrote training
into Direct
myself and then and then once that
started unspooling the way it went I
wrote Harsh Times okay I'm going to
direct this and yeah I mortgaged my
house it was like like
I put everything I had into that
and then I just went for it um
that was terrifying a bit terrifying a
bit um
but I loved
working with actors like it's not
that that collaborative thing and and
for me it's like we're all in it
together and I think like Hollywood
can be super classist like
um and dudes show up and they're so
about their ego and their identity and
I'm the director I'm the producer and
that's their armor and that identity of
who they are
um
and then if that's how you're rolling
you can't let anyone see behind the
curtain you can't let anyone see the
magic trick you know and
so for me it's it's a collaborative
process and the most important thing or
the actor's name I face up there
um
and yeah I just fell in love with with
that process and hunting truth like it's
like a team of people together hunting
truth
the [__] what's better than that you
know we create our own reality you know
and
so what is the co-created reality on
that set and then how do you get there
like you know
that's that's my whole world now it's
like as a country we don't really have a
co-created reality anymore how do you
mean
the mythopedic reality the United States
what is the United States was it a
corporate Endeavor for the monetization
of enslaved people from the get and
that's all it ever was was it people
seeking freedom from tyranny and against
the crown and all that like like what is
our stories of people or are we a good
people are we bad people are we a bad
Nation right and so when you don't even
know
what is the common reality that we share
what what is the space that we are
creating together that's a huge [__]
opportunity for the Predators to come in
and just tear the ass at it everything
yeah like again which is also an
exercise of violence and control and
power and if you understand that
language
shit's real clear right like like it's
beautiful the way you have to admire a
shark you know
the construction of it and that that
speed and everything and how it hunts
the same thing's happening in our world
now like
so just find find truth within that I
think that's all we can do now is
surround ourselves with truth create
safe opportunities for it and then just
explore like get in it after you get
done with with with Harsh Times you like
all right you're full on you're like
this this is what I'm [__] doing now
right it was it was a horrific
experience and it was hard and I didn't
understand it and I didn't know what the
job was but I knew I had to keep doing
it yeah you know and and then just yeah
a lot of it was like
who am I what's my role in this thing
you know
um
like yeah Hollywood's awful man because
it's like if you have
like I'm [__] up you know I [__] up
life you know of like like all my issues
psychologically personality wise
whatever that I'm working through as a
Storyteller as a father as a friend all
that stuff
um and then you get into an industry
which is going to feed
your worst solutions to your personality
business is so dark man it's it's it's
it's pimpnosis it's a pimp game right
and and in Hollywood they keep all the
talent apart God forbid two directors
ever talk yeah God forbid the director
gets alone in the room with the writer
it's all about gatekeeping it's all
about control it's all about atomizing
people you know
and then when people come together and
bring truth it just blows the doors off
of that
that's like the one thing they can't
[__] take away it's it's happening
and and I feel like the knowledge or the
ability to find that truth is is
disappearing you know and the craft and
the magic of filmmaking is is dying a
thousand percent what's the biggest
enemy
corporate industrialized production and
post-production processes so let's say
you have an entity that's taken over
most of the film and television
production right and that entities from
Silicon Valley right so they're already
there's like a certain way to view
processes right and we got to get these
costs under control these [__]
creative people are making these crazy
decisions we got to get that under
control great okay well now the post
person is going to dictate camera
pipeline processing look
production person is going to dictate
lighting package how you light the set
the time the scheduling right oh [__] we
don't have time all right just put a
stick of top light up there and then
just do a front fill and we'll knock out
three setups in this great like nobody
cares anymore like like the the effort
it takes
for like movie Magic like the little box
emoji movie Magic and you sprinkle it
and all that
that's time that's money that's a good
Crew That's a crew that cares crazy
commitment crazy commitment from your
[__] soul and
all that's been ripped apart now it's
just like stamping widgets out and you
have people growing up in this culture
who have no idea what real filmmaking is
yeah what about what real film is like
do you feel like the audience hunger for
like for do you feel like the hunger is
still there the 100 yeah right and and
and and people don't want art delivered
to them in in in in sort of like well
this is our for these kinds of people
but that's awesome Art's a funny word
man I mean at the end of the day I have
no [__] Illusions what we're doing it
is for-profit Corporate speech
it's a product it is for-profit
Corporate speech that's that's what
we're doing right that's the mission
that's the exercise and these people
over here this investment fund or this
line of credit that the studio has they
want to see Returns on their money how
do you get those returns well there's
casting you cast somebody there's like a
matrix there's like paperwork on you
guys right so I can look up your Q score
I can look up
how much uh your movie is going to sell
in the UK or English-speaking
territories or you know in the
francophone territories dude I Crush in
Bangladesh I got like 13 Bangladeshi
kids bro but that's that's it it's all
micro targeted now and so like just how
even a movie's engineered and they're so
disingenuous too because at the end of
the day like even a studio everything's
already pre-financed right they got
letters of credit they got this they got
that they're throwing up a few million
in cap funding or something right it's
so risk-averse it's ridiculous what's
your biggest what's your biggest
heartbreak in in in in the film industry
with the thing that's hurt the most all
right so Hollywood I tell people is like
watching someone you love get [__] by
someone you hate
so
[Laughter]
I mean there's a couple of them I mean
uh
you know the big one is like suicide
squad that [__] that [__] broke me that
handed me my ass how so
uh
come right off Fury right had had the
town in my hand could have done anything
and I did do anything and
you know go on this journey with it and
the same thing like like authentic
truthful let's do all the rehearsal
let's really get in each other's Souls
let's create this amazing collaborative
thing right and then
I dropped my director cut you know your
10-week assemble it's a [__] assembly
of 10 weeks for a movie that big come on
you know and
Deadpool opened right and then they
never tested Batman versus Superman so
so they put the movie out there and they
never did a test and they they
were expecting a different result and
then they got hammered by all the
critics and then it's like okay
we're going to turn David Ayers dark
Soulful movie into a [__] comedy now
I became the bad guy narratively oh it
was a tough director he's hard to work
with or this or that right because as
they're [__] you you were like stop
[__] yeah and as in the but the
producers themselves are like like
producer Studio people Executives I'm
not calling anybody out because we're
all like at the end of the day like
it's [__] business right yeah I get
it
um but
The Narrative that like Oh I'm a hard
I'm hard to work with and I'm the
problem only puts more value and equity
in their career and and that's kind of
like what my path has been like I wrote
the first fast and furious man when I
when I got that script that [__] was set
in New York it was all Italian kids
right I went to stuber Scott stuber who
ran um he was running uh Universal at
the time
who hired me I'm like bro I'm not going
to take it unless I can set it in LA and
make it look like the people I know in
LA right so then I started like writing
in uh people of color and writing in the
street stuff and writing in the culture
and and no one knew [__] about street
racing at the time and I went to like a
shop in the valley met with like the
first guys that were doing the hacking
of the fuel curves for the injectors and
stuff like that and they just figured it
out and they're showing and I'm like oh
[__] you I'm gonna put that in the movie
you know like
it's what you do man and and biggest
franchise in Hollywood I don't have any
of it I don't know really I got nothing
to show for it nothing because of the
way the business works right and the
narrative is I didn't do [__] right so
it's like
people hijack narratives control
narratives create narratives to empower
themselves right and and because I was
always an outsider and because like
like
I don't go to the [__] parties right
I don't go to the meals I don't do any
of that stuff yeah the people that did
were able to control managed narratives
because they're socializing that part of
the problem I was never socializing that
part of the problem so I was always like
like the dark creative dude beware you
know and and now it's like okay great
[__] all the middlemen right
I get it it's up to me I gotta
self-rescue right I can [__] whine
about getting shot at and all the rounds
I've taken over my career I gotta
self-rescue and I gotta create an
ecology where it's safe for me to be
creative and that's it that's what I'm
doing how do you do that
access to money people access to
decision makers
um there's so many layers of decision
makers who has the actual green light
Authority right how do you get a
relationship with someone with that
Authority do you feel like there's
people out there that are that that
recognize that's [__] good handful
yeah because I think everybody
recognizes what's good but your ability
to execute something good is not really
there but you come out like you do Harsh
Times end of watching fear like what the
[__] is anybody gonna like how are these
people taking your movie away from you
like like how how is there a movie yeah
but but somebody somebody knows what
what the real score is there but it's
like
they never tested my cut and the thing
is I have it I [__] have a copy of it
right and if I didn't oh my God because
everyone I've shown the cut has the same
reaction rage yeah like this is the
movie we wanted why didn't we get this
WOW right wow and and and then like I'm
such a [__] bro about all this stuff
but like I've seen that like release the
air cut I've seen that on like what can
that get released I mean would you want
it to be released it's it's like
Schrodinger's cut now it's almost like
is it more legendary to see it or more
legendary to not see it yeah like I
talked to James gone and look they got
their own he's trying to figure it out
loud and you know it's it's possible but
they want to get some scores on the
board first yeah yeah
um I have I could show people I could
you know like but
it's it's tough because it's like it's I
want to [__] move on from and I want
to heal from it you know and it pisses
me off because like like dude I was
coming off Fury yeah right yeah and
during a time during Suicide Squad when
the dailies were coming in people are
like oh [__] maybe air is going to take
over DC yeah and there's all those Game
of Thrones in there the palace politics
were insane right and the [__] that was
really going on
bro all right okay you know and then and
then they're shooting at me and every
time you know the new movie comes out a
new movie would come out in the space
the Press would come at me again
right over like
like that's what became so [__] up is
I became a talking point inside of the
marketing for these other projects in a
negative way and I'm sitting there like
what is happening you know it's like
it's
I remember talking to people like do
what you know like talking to Kevin
Vance and yeah and and and Sensei and
and and you know and then like I mean
because that that process of making that
movie sounds [__] righteous and
[__] like everybody was really
putting in Joel and and will and all
that
I mean so let me ask you now like do you
do you wish you would never do you wish
you had never done it like because
you're also somebody who's like like the
pain in the lumps is also what [__]
defines you and gets you where like
you're always [__] forward moving
like yeah dude I I remember in the the
fury press tour being in in uh some
[__] room and some fancy ass [__]
hotel
and and and you were you were meeting I
mean you probably can't [__] talk
about you you were meeting like a very
famous actor and and and and horribly
unlucky to you guys you got seated right
next to like me and Shia and Mike and
and you're meeting about suicide squad
and Shia like got up and he's like he's
like what the [__] G why are you doing
this [__] movie [__] you for even
wanting to be in this movie you're
throwing it away bro don't [__] do it
bro and like uh should listen to him
dude I remember seeing like thinking I
remember being like shy dude like what
are you [__] because for me at that
point anybody said anything about it
about you met like dude I'll kill like
you know but it was shy and I was like
what are you doing bro I don't know I I
it's like like you said it's a wildly
successful movie and it's like and now
you're in this like place in your life I
mean how do you look back on that like I
understand the pain that it's caused you
but but but like do you wish I mean I
don't even know what that [__] does
anyways I'm ambivalent man like like
part of like I have to own my life and I
have to own my journey in in my
experiences right
it
you know it's like like Gone With the
Wind and there's that moment where
Scarlett or Hera is like you know I will
never go hungry again you know like that
taught me I have to have control over my
work I have to have control over my work
and I won't get in a situation where I
don't have that control over again
because
they will strap a bomb to your back and
bury you in a [__] crater they don't
give a [__] like
little rip your guts out if it serves
their empire like for-profit corporate
speech right quarterly oh if this
quarter we're able to save on payroll by
firing people and this movie made a
profit and we sold secondary that's all
they [__] care about I don't care
about you everyone's disposable man like
and it's like taking me kind of coming
to terms with the reality of Hollywood
you know and what it is and it's it's
been so confusing and then at the same
time this is the business that's changed
my life this business has built my house
this is a business it's given me these
opportunities to travel the world and
see things and meet people you know so
so it's tough It's like you know yeah
you get petted and slapped you know
sometimes at the same time dude that's
[__] great man that's so [__]
right I don't know man you know the
other uh I don't know when was it what
was that thing for dimmer a month ago
like [__] Nemer
but you know man they were like they
were honored you know they were honoring
Newton you know what I mean and they
they did a screening event of watch and
like you know like the whole [__]
Department was there bro and it's like
you know like Mikey Mikey came and I
came and and Kevin was there and and it
was like
I don't know man like I remember you I
remember you talking about Fury and
you're like yeah dude like you're like
you're never gonna pay for a beer again
dude like like military like you know
like any tanker is kind of like and like
dude that that is like a truer thing
it's never been said and that it's like
literally the honor just being in that
anyways in the experience but that part
of it like doing that right and knowing
that like we put there was no doubt
about why we made that movie and the
same is true for law enforcement with
End of Watch and it's like Bro you've
like like now is that like your North
Star like do you like is that it's
confusing to me it's confusing to me
because like
my life is so intense and so much [__]
happens and such a velocity and it's
like you know and a watch was like 2008.
Fury was like you know 20. 16 or
something yeah and
it's just like
who was I how did I do that how did I
create that and and it's weird because
like you know at the time I was like
super married and the kids and
everything and that was all my life and
I'm my castle and my safety was I able
to go into those places and create
because I had such safety in my personal
life and and now I'm like trying to
create that that sense again you know do
I have to feel safe like that to create
like that like what conditions
to to pull that out and then again like
and then I wrestle with like
culture like do people want to hear from
you do people want to hear what I have
to say do I have a right to tell stories
you know
um like deep like that you know like
like what are we doing you know what am
I doing that's just like a [__]
humble and and like like like honest
like thing to say man you know what I
mean and like there's all I mean you
know as well as me like only
you know that like that understanding
and that honesty and that humility like
only only the truth and only good come
from that just you get like everything's
been Stripped Away everything's been
Stripped Away and
and
you know like I'm on social media a lot
and it's just fascinating because now
like the audience wants to know who you
are you know and it's like
you know when I was about to get nuked
on Twitter after another DC movie was
coming out and I had to be the devil you
know
um I was like [__] it and I just wrote
up my life and tweeted it because you
could see I could see like like I'm
really good at man like
strategic Communications and seeing how
shit's moving and unfolding I don't know
I'm gonna get nuked on this one so this
is my life this is my story this is who
I am I put it out there and everything
stopped overnight it was like of course
you know publicist like nightmare when
you're gone but it's not
counter-intuitive stuff works
um
but right now it's just like
you know you're saying with fury like I
can't walk onto a military base without
getting mocked right and then like oh
hey you know my Squadron watch Fury
together you know before we deployed and
went down range and we always remember
that moment together or
like like my homie Sean you know who
found something in it and and my whole
thing now is like like I'm so [__]
beat down that I'm trying to like find
Value what is my value as a human being
away from
here are things you have done that
symbolize you and give your life value
none of that means [__] I'm here right
now bro like past is gone like like what
is now what is tomorrow what is that
and and it's so hard to create and it's
in in like the world
like world don't want to be saved right
now you know and and I'm like Captain
Save A Hoe Storyteller like like hey use
deeper human [__] no I'm gonna want that
you know so it's like
like
I don't know man like I'm desperate for
authenticity and I think that's what's
lacking in all our [__] now like
nothing's [__] authentic and like my
dream would be like to have like a cast
for six months and just Workshop
something and then like Workshop
rehearse right find truth go deep deep
deep and then go to set I mean I feel
like there's so much [__] hunger for
that bro but like the people you know
you said something before about like
creating you know it's like something
shy and I got into real heavy I think
starting with us over there but just
sort of like the the circumstances
you're in the people around you your
family the the people you [__] with
um the desire that I think you you know
real well just like sometimes you feel
you've got to like bleed out to create
and you gotta like [__] up the world and
just like Drop it but right it's like
what comes feeling knowing the power
that knowing like if you're the kind of
person that can walk in a room and
create danger and Chaos it's like if you
can do that on a set it's [__] magic
so it's like do you still do that in
life I'm just wondering like right like
the whole tortured artist thing like
I think there's something in an artist's
nature that that can be chaotic and
that exploration and energy that gets
reflected back to you from that chaos
you can then put in your work but it's
also a trap because then that becomes
what you're doing yeah and it can get
out of control you know like I used to
drink a lot I was bad [__] bad and
it's you know it's been forever and ever
since I've had a drink but like I
thought that that was part of who I was
you know and part of my creative
identity you know and it's like like oh
I get high and [__] you know slam
some tall cans and you know write weird
[__] and
I felt like I needed that crutch to tell
stories but my best scripts all wrote
sober you know so
but it's it's a trap but like
and now
everybody's so constrained and
behaviorally constrained and everyone's
so watched we didn't have cell phones
when I was a kid man you know can you
imagine dudes would get a pillowcase and
go through the whole bus getting
everyone's bus passes you know I'm not
giving a [__] right like no cell phones
like like now everybody's observing you
and watching you and and reverse
engineering everything you do for malice
right plus there's also a sense of like
all right if you're older there's a
[__] Target on your back I'm gonna
shoot you off your horse I'm gonna get
your job [__] you know and
that's
that's the the work environment now
that's the world now right like like
trying to find fault with people
you know and are there are there valid
reasons for that [__] yeah it's a
reaction of course people are reacting
to [__]
this dog [__] that's been happening in
our society man like you know how do you
share in that space how do you create
something that's going to be truthful
and uplifting and human and Powerful you
know and then and potentially offensive
and potentially less scary potentially
make you [__] uncomfortable well now
you're a business right and okay well I
just invested I'm on the line for 70
million dollars and we're gonna do you
know 30 million dollar p a commitment
that's 100 million dollars right there
um oh no the subject man's matter cause
it to get canceled or an actor had an
incident and now it's canceled so now
you're 100 100 million dollar
Investments worth nothing and it's a tax
write-off you know and and so if you're
a manager and you're managing multiple
projects
decision making gets real simple right
you're not going to take any risks
you're not going to put it out there
you're going to go for old IP you're
going to execute it in a proven way
you're going to cast people that you
know are safe and feel safe you're in a
hire a director who can just get the
[__] in the can according to the DGA MBA
talk to the actors check all the boxes
check the legal stuff like
that that's for-profit corporate speech
and for you personally just like about
forget like just the ales of the the
industry which is completely [__] up
but for you personally like your
optimization like do you feel like you
can operate when you have
peace or or some sort of like balance
and Harmony in your life you can still
bring chaos and danger to your work or
are you are you do you want to figure
that out like are you figuring that out
like what do you again going back to
that whole thing that you know me and
shy have been going back and forth for
for like [__] years
I mean
I could I can bring whatever I need to
bring in the moment that I need it like
I'm confident of that
um I'm also lately
like everything I've gone through I'm a
lot gentler with people you know like
and I think it's like you'll get this
also it's like a generational thing
right the way we grew up it's just like
keep your [__] mouth shut show up
work hard and eventually someone's gonna
be like you come here you carry the ball
yeah you know and okay you're a dick to
me for three years and now I'm cool
like that that sort of
you know Vibe is gone
um
like what does the individual need am I
pushing my own [__] onto you am I like
Oh I'm a director and you're creating a
character and I'm helping you do that
how much of that is my own ego about how
I need to see myself you know and so
once you start seeing that piece you
take that away then okay you as a human
being what energy do you need from me so
you feel safe
so you can do your job
um
so just yeah just being more respectful
of people you know and even the cultural
stuff like like oh [__] you know but
like
like yeah let's wake up how how do my
words impact other people how does my
art impact other people how how does my
art impact different communities like
how
you know
like being responsible and taking
ownership of what you're putting out of
the world is important too so it's just
like
I'm just
trying to have a conversation with the
world and and yeah
what's the most important thing in your
life would you say my kids yeah you talk
about that yeah it's just like like um
yeah I went through you know intense
divorce and coming from the world of
like a couple that no one ever ever ever
thought would yeah fail yeah blew my
mind and you know and a lot of it was
just how I grew up how we grew up not
having tools not having
the ability to communicate what are the
patterns you see as a child you know
all that I've gone through like one
point has been like seven hours of
therapy a week trying to deal all this
[__] you know and
at a certain point you crack yourself
open and and
you know with these kids I went from
like
yeah the director the Hollywood director
show up at the house eat dinner you know
um very formal old school you know and
and I've had to learn how to have
relationships with my kids you know
um on their terms without me pushing an
image of myself into their world what's
required to do that
being honest with who you are like
um identity like identity like this
concept of identity is something I [__]
with so much now
um and because I've had to be all these
different people and and I I created
what I thought was a successful
construction totally and I'm just
playing a [__] character you know and
then it's like like
being loving myself enough to not be
afraid to be seen is what turned it
around for me and and a lot of that was
like like again a lot of therapy and
like oh these things that happened to me
that's trauma oh that's bad oh that's
not love oh survival fight or flight is
not love
like
[__] pain and Trauma and red flags
are not love just because your nervous
system like Jacks you the thing thinks
it's home yeah yeah yeah because that's
where you feel at home yeah it's not it
ain't it and and then it'd be vulnerable
you know and coming from a world like
like Series in the military and
everything and and you know talk about
toxic masculine and all that [__] were
like shut down not revealing emotion not
being present having a Persona like
stripping all that away and then
and then you know like most of my life
I'm just running from pain right running
from intense [__] pain and eventually
I had to stop and feel it you know and
that's been these past few years and
it's like
like oh [__] I have a heart oh I'm a
human being oh I'm capable of love
because I just talk I told a really a
lot of [__] bad stories about myself
growing up I was a piece of [__] I was
getting up in prison I'm gonna [__]
kill people I'm not a good guy well I'm
not trustworthy you know violent fear
this guy whatever and and I internalized
all that and so just a lot of work to
get those stories out the stories you
tell yourself but the stories other
people have told about you
discovering yourself
and then feeling safe to be seen
and and you've and the main motivator in
this is is having some sort of like on
it is your relationship with your kids
yeah that's that's the the yeah it's
deeper than I understood because like
like straight up like like the divorce
is like hell on Earth right and
and I was like for a minute
it was so confusing and painful it was
like well maybe the best thing I can do
is get out of these kids lives and end
this contention and pain and I'm I'm a
toxic piece of [__] anyway so me not
being around can only be good for them
right and
so it's like and then my ancestral
wounds of like my dad and you know which
is a [__] major form of rejection
right you know child me is like oh that
homeboy didn't [__] love me enough to
hang out and and protect me and stop me
from the horrific abuse that was about
to unfold right so I'll work through
that and I gotta [__] love him and
figure out how to love him and love a
little boy that experienced that
before I can even love my own kids like
bro and
I mean
it's just
that whole process taught me that
there's more to me than I thought you
know like like um I'm like a fake ass
empty room like I don't exist I'm just a
collection of masks and personalities
and reactions in any given situation
no no you're you have a heart you you
you can you can love your and your love
has value
and it's okay for you to love like all
that was new to me bro yeah man yeah man
yeah dude it's and and and and where are
you where are you at with your kids now
I mean I know like fatherhood is just
like it's like a series of [__]
getting slammed like just bailing your
[__] ass off and you kind of keep
going and I know there's ups and downs
but where do you feel like you you're at
with it with the relationship with oh no
yeah like like no matter what stories
they've been told about me they've seen
enough with their own eyes at this point
what is it that they've seen just I'm
there you're there yeah yeah I watch the
map forum and fought for them and you
know
and it's it's like
just creating a safe space for them you
know like parenting them parenting
myself
what the [__] you know
what the [__] it's beautiful it's dude I
mean
yeah you know it's it's it's cool uh
it's really cool I mean again maybe back
to that football coach thing but it's
it's it's [__] really cool to sit
down with you like this man and and uh
see you like this and like you know
because it it you know it was it always
was a little bit for me you know you
know again I felt so like protected and
and I always felt loved by you I always
felt like even just like you choosing me
was just such it was such a huge thing
for me man I took it so seriously such a
miracle in my life you know and like
getting to do that
but I also like and I didn't know
whether it was the movie or not but I
always felt like man like you know you
it's all there was always this thing
like you know you could you could never
really get in never really open up like
you would see the like he's the boss man
he's a [__] gangster like he's a real
gangster like the way he handles himself
like I'd seen that but I also this
unbelievable ability to like break
people down and open them up and like
and talk about the most intricate and
and and and most like a net no filmmaker
no artist I've ever worked with has been
able to like you know play play people's
[__] chords of the most intricate
every ounce of the pain where the pain
and the Darkness is like just as
beautiful as is dark and like so
fascinated by it but yet so like you
ain't gonna get there with me and I see
like and and you and and and just talk
just a little bit man and we don't have
to go but like like just a little bit
about Kev and and just because he's he
you know I think he means just like a
ton of everyone in this room and like
you know you brought Kevin into my life
but like who is Kevin to you and like
the work that you guys have done and
Kevin Vance
um yeah uh
known him a minute uh
uh met him in a parallel life and uh
watching him
transform because like when I'm when I
met him he was just in it yeah like like
and he had had that you know hangover of
like
the military
um I mean the secret to the military is
like a handful of people do all the work
right so it's like oh we have all these
Army divisions well they're kind of just
holding Security on the Edge at the end
of the day while
you know this handful of very highly
trained amazing people it kind of gets
it done
at
incredible
moral hazard blowback cost to self and
and he was like
one of the first people I met from that
community
and it's so funny because you know when
I met him is like solving the community
and solidly in that
identity I am an elite operator that is
who I am yeah and
and he evolved out of that and didn't
need that to be his identity and then
went on this healing journey and started
helping people like right left and
center and was really a [__] Pioneer
now and now he's out there like like
trying to save lives okay rescuing
people because yeah these dudes in these
communities
they take so much trauma on our behalf
um
massive amounts of trauma and they do
really dark things on our behalf
and
that whole Warrior culture has its own
thing going on
and it's not a safe space to like be
vulnerable and talk about your heart and
I've seen it in the gang world too where
the homies are like
becoming conscious you know and like we
used to be achievement back Australia
cavemen and now it's like oh we're
humans and we have this holistic life
and can impact people
and there's something about people that
have seen that extreme violence and
lived in it and been around it that
pushes them closer towards a bigger
human truth and they bring that back
into the regular life and that's why
I've always connected with that because
it's I felt like they're in the real
world and everyone else is in the fake
world [__] neighborhood I mean I I
honestly I think that more than anything
else is why like I'm trying to do this
because it's like look if I can
[__] hat like if you say that and and
like Kevin says that you know it's like
everybody else in their life can like
stop hiding behind all that [__] it's
like look look at who's saying it dude
and it's like look at the potential like
I know you've been through it but like
look at the potential for like look at
what you can create look at what you how
you can serve you know like that's it
right there is is how do you serve and
I'm wrestling my journey right now at
the moment it's just like like
am I worthy of serving you know and it's
like okay track record these movies
impact these communities of Health
people okay there's evidence there that
I am worthy to serve I would say so bro
I just gotta figure it out but like
everything's ego you know like like
ego and Trauma and pain and how you
shape your personality to not feel the
pain you know and it's like
I don't know you know like like the
homies [__] gangsters right like
typically they're smart as [__] as far
as [__] they're like
rounded people like they see the world
in a different way
they have this specialized knowledge
about life and people
and
there there's a deep deep truth that
they find and especially the survivors
in that space and like the guys that
[__] hang and and that energy you
know like
There's Something Beautiful to it
and then if you can get away from all
the [__] I'm [__] this I'm not
oh okay how do I help the Young Guns how
do I help these families how do I like
people are talking about
trauma and [__] that's happening to them
when no one ever did before which is
amazing but like
it's self-rescue all these communities
have to self-rescue right because right
now
you know the way our society is
you know
it's the opposite of cohesion it's the
opposite of unity it's the opposite of
coming together so like all these
communities have to self-rescue there's
so many [__] agendas but if you can
just human connection and like
I don't know like if like if I got
whacked out on the streets when I was
like 18 doing dumb [__] right like there
wouldn't there wouldn't be these movies
that that have left a positive impact
and and it's like for all my like oh on
the back I'm a piece of [__] and I hate
myself and blah blah
I got it that's objective that that's
value in that that means I brought
something of value to this world and and
yeah man like if we can just get out of
these negative self stories and and stop
doing that in all these communities and
and just hunt down these negative
narratives that are that are just tying
us to the ground like that's the way to
do it you you you you talk about your
own negative [__] and the [__]
that's like your own negative self-serve
believe me I know it's so [__] well
but then the first thing you said to
like from from this
this omnipresent [__] view when you
look at it yeah but look at these look
at these things on the board that like I
know like have helped people or change
people right it's like I go through that
same [__] so in this National or
International whatever in this state
that we are right now what role does
does art play in in in in rescue arts
and nuclear weapon art is so
ridiculously [__] powerful the most
powerful medium is film right so you
have acting of directing you have music
you have you have art Visual Arts you
know it's it's it's a collaboration of
multiple artistic mediums creating this
illusion of reality right and you know
it's like
like when I saw a Scarface for the first
time it's been like nine or something
you know
and
for my world at the time it was like
there's a bigger more important world
there's a lot more going on than you
knew and people come in a lot different
shapes and varieties and abilities and
and then you knew and it was just like
this keyhole into this world right and
that's one of the reasons why art is so
controlled why the industry is so
controlled why everything is so
incredibly gate kept because God forbid
man this piece of primordial magic leak
through the system and transform the
world like I believe that you can create
something that can transform the world
instantly like it's that powerful it's
that powerful and that terrifies The
Gatekeepers and terrifies people that
that want these negative narratives
about ourselves to be out there
you know and want control of it for
themselves and want to be the only ones
that do it they say well it's [__] I
mean I don't know how's the world really
work right
it's about money or is it not about
money you know what I mean and who has
the money who has the violence who has a
monopoly on violence who controls
violence like what what is this world
what is this Society it's a for-profit
corporate [__] machine man it is what
it is you know how do you find humanity
inside of that how do you
you know and and I I believe that human
beings are
incredibly capable like like one of us
can change the world and and imagine if
we all got together and started
co-creating a positive reality together
like how transformative that would be
but if my entire
wealth my generational wealth is based
upon
you know keeping you nervous so you make
a consumer choice and buy my product to
satisfy that that emptiness in your soul
last thing I [__] want is some sort
of like mass self-realization and rising
up [__] that man I want to smash you
[__] and Shake you upside down
get all your money
[Laughter]
uh was there uh is it is there is there
anything else that like I know I I think
I know what the [__] answer is there
is there anything else that like you
came here today is there anything else
that you wanted to sort of like
talk about or or is there anything you
got for me or is there anything that you
just like feel like you you want to say
I mean I don't know I just trip on you
um you know remember when I first met
you I was at the audition you know and
your energy was very against yourself
you know you're like this you know your
whole energy field was just very much
you know and it was like
like you're trying to brute force your
way out of something you know and study
and education and and studying the
dramatic stuff and like you could just
feel
I have this one road that's magnetically
pulling me down and I have this other
road that I can apply myself and force
my way into and I'm not sure if I'm
gonna do that
and as and now you're like
I mean I'm gonna you know you bring a
Consciousness like you're getting people
to talk about [__] and talk about [__]
in a conscious way and so like you
figured something out
put yourself on a different track and
now you're helping other people and
that's [__] beautiful thanks man is
what is [__] beautiful I appreciate
you saying that bro and then to get like
the homies and the street cats and dudes
like that talking about because that's
the whole thing like I can't talk about
how I feel and I'm in a lot of pain so
I'm gonna go shoot a [__]
right
or feel better and I'm going to bump my
[__] and drive around the [__] hood
on Saturday man [__] yeah you know
because y'all got one of mine yeah you
know what I mean so it's like look at
what I just did good I'm powerful you
know and but if you can [__] well my dad
never came home or he was a drunk or you
know my mama used to whoop me or this or
that like like
trauma shapes us and it's shame you know
and
you know for me every murder is an act
of Shame you know like there's something
you're ashamed of you've been made to
feel shame about yourself and
just healing shame will I think reduce
violence and make lives better you know
and and for men and
people of the violent world and who get
that and uncomfortable know how to
navigate about that to show
vulnerability and weakness and then you
realize like and Kevin's doing that you
see that with the work he's doing
is
to be able to exercise violence and be a
[__] dangerous person right like I'll
go and I'll kick your door and I'll kill
your whole [__] family [__] you right
that's a certain energy to have that
capability and that energy
but also to have the loving side and the
protective side and the nourishing side
toxic masculinity is just simply
I think power and aggression without
love and compassion you know and and I
think that like it it's so often I meant
you've seen it in a million times
especially in our [__] it's like it
often manifests itself in somebody who's
faking both it's like somebody who's if
you've really done that [__] you know
it's coming from shame you know the
horrors of it you know what it's like to
look at somebody right before they're
about to get hurt sometimes by you and
you're going to do it anyways and you
know that you got to go home with that
yeah and like you you know you know that
it's always both sides of the coin like
you know it man and like these guys know
it then there's a lot of people who just
you know [__] and where they wear
their clothes and [__] say a lot of
loud [__] and and and they're so scared
because they know it's not real that
it's just like I would never show any
[__] weaknesses this is [__] [__]
and it's like yeah man it's it's it's
it's uh
and you know man it's like doing that
film that we did it was like
yeah control chaos and danger and
[__] like getting us to like bear our
souls and all that [__] at the end of
the day man it's like the one thing like
every guy that you had us talk to it's
like it was [__] horrifying like you
couldn't see like like being a loader
like you couldn't see [__] you can see
she didn't know at any second you know
what I mean and he said like what does
that do you know what I mean it's like
yeah that's like Brave and it's
courageous it's also [__] like deeply
horrifying and it's like just brutal and
that whole generation no one could talk
about what they went through you know
and like my superpowers was always able
to get people to talk about whatever
like like I don't judge you know tell me
your story I'm not gonna judge I'm gonna
understand it it's all love and and then
to get like you know I'd bring the
veterans to set and everything and you
know bring guys out watching these guys
and I just watch their eyes you know and
just watch how they're looking at
everything and and you could feel their
energy change you know and it was just
like
like I don't even know what to say to
him like I can you can feel their energy
you can feel that whole War into their
nervous system and they get really quiet
and they're looking around and it's it's
just like
and you can feel
at the end of it and it's time to go and
you can like they're so raw and
emotional and they're so stoic and
trying to hide that and you can just
feel like everybody they lost every pain
everything it's like right there on them
you know and for me
it's honorable to bring out oh here's a
World War II veteran he lived the story
he's out here on set he's seeing he's in
a Living Museum it's a recreation of
what what he did and now he's witnessing
this and I was able to do this for this
guy and and you know we'd stop the set
everyone would stop [__] working like
over talk to him like
I don't know man like the things
you know men are [__] up right now and
and the things that we're asked to do
and then no one gives us the tools
to be compassionate leaders and and
rescue our own communities and to help
ourselves like
it's it's [__] tragic you know
what do you what do you do with your own
son like what do you how how do you how
do you Broach that
I mean
I think a lot of it's like like what I
don't do right so I'm not like drunk
around my kids I don't drink I don't
like
um but I'm also honest you [__] like
like they know how the world Works they
know what's going on you know they've
seen it
um the hardest thing
is like they're not me you know and I
think like you know I got a kid is is 14
and it's like
when I was his age oh my God totally
dude I was like stealing cars on his
[__] head
you know it's heated up I was like like
incomprehensible Madness like
bust into a bar and take all their
[__] kegs you know just because you
can't unlike stupid stuff and
they have no that's not their world but
then their world is their world and I
have to respect their world and that's
the hardest part is like understanding
their Viewpoint their hearts and being
compassionate and not pushing
me into them but letting them push
themselves into me and and what do you
is part of that like do you catch
yourself doing that sometimes and then
do what do you do you admit it do you
like no it's just like like
why am I saying what I'm saying is it
because I'm hurt and somehow saying that
makes me feel better versus let's be
present you know so a lot of it's just
being present yeah learning how to be
present um that's like in the early part
of the divorce it was it was awful it
was really hard to be around the kids
because it was like they're in so much
pain I'm in so much pain I got no
[__] tools you know it's a disaster
everything's a disaster
and then now just chill just kicking it
you know like
and it's their world I gotta hand this
world over to them here guys sorry
I know uh it's a [__] cheese [__]
dick question man but what what I'm so
sorry bro I didn't like think about
beforehand but now it's in my head I had
passed so so what would you what would
you say to 14 year old Dave
and
you're not a bad person
like
14 year old me it was all about armor
and creating a Persona that's when I
discovered that there's a lot of value
in being scary
you know intimidation and [__] like that
like that's that's where I learned that
language and
it's so much harder
to be authentic and put your heart on
the line and expose yourself and be
vulnerable like run around like a
[__] [__] Mad Dogging people any
[__] yeah yeah that's [__] so true I
feel this and articulate that feeling
that's
yeah
Amber you remember how I did that
[__] uh audition and then I had to
come back and do that thing with you and
do you remember how that went went down
with you and Brad in your office do you
remember anything uh about that I'm like
Dory I got four seconds of memory man
yeah dude so well it was a big [__]
so uh you know like I did it right I did
that the thing and and you you were kind
of stoked on it and I think there's like
some you know some famous people and
[__] that wanted to play the part and
stuff like that and then and then uh I
think Brad wanted one of them and then
uh and then uh you were like look dude
like the only way this works I mean
you're so [__] cool man you're like
look man I still have the [__]
letters you were like you've got to come
into my office and you got to read with
him and like show him what the [__] is
up you know what I mean and like let you
know just come and do it and I think I
did hit you with like six million
questions about that and I went to your
office dude there's these steps by your
office I came like six and a half hours
beforehand just like sitting there dude
and uh this [__] came in this
[__] gave me yeah that long hair
she's just and he was like man are you
as sick as zombies as I am some [__]
cheesy I love that guy but like it's
like the cheesy I was like what'd you
think of that on the way over here or
some [__] and uh and we start doing it
but you know man like I was already like
off book for the whole [__] movie and
I was like in my [__] I you know and
he's like reading it because we're still
like [__] you know half a year eight
months from [__] even going to the
three months of [__] pre-production
because you [__] rip us apart and
[__] destroy our souls and [__] we
read it and I was like this isn't
[__] happening and so I at the last
one you're like all right just do it one
more time you were like sitting behind
your desk
and uh I was like it's not [__]
happening and he was like sitting down
the whole time I kept standing and I was
like man steak but he was like trying to
keep up because he's reading so I like
smacked the paper out of his hand and I
[__] lifted his uh I've lifted him
out of his chair man and and uh I
started screaming him and then I went
home and I was like crying dude I I
wrote you I never wrote emails back then
dude and I wrote you this email about
I'm so sorry I let you down
and he wrote me back like he wrote me
back like a few days later he's like
dude like you didn't like you're fine
bro like you didn't let anybody down and
I was like you're like you're fine dude
it was just a long time ago I didn't but
yeah I don't write emails I don't write
them now yeah I don't [__] with emails
not much has changed yeah yeah but then
man I'm yeah anyway man but you know you
had me like from the beginning like you
you [__] you like a lot of people
didn't do that you know in the beginning
man a lot of people don't do it like
they see the best thing but they're like
yeah we can't do that and you said from
the beginning you're like dude like I
got you bro and that that was uh that
was [__] great man
that was a good show yeah
I desperately want that kind of
experience again me too you know me too
it's that commitment and you got to be
willing you you were down to go on the
journey
um
that's the other thing is like I
remember I remember so palpably like
Brad there telling us all every day it
will never be this good it will never be
this good like when you're like making
us come to work to sit in a [__] tank
for all exterior tanks day after day
after day like can we not come come in
like no you guys gotta operate the tank
yeah well no one will see us bro it's
just like we're staring at Brad's ass
because his head pops out everyone so on
and we're just in there smoking
cigarettes for like 16 hours in the cold
for months at a time like there's no
chance you're gonna get seen get your
[__] costume on get all this [__]
[__] off [__] carving his face up to
sit in a [__] tank for exterior tanks
it was the best and he would be like it
will never get this good this is the
best you'll ever have it bro it was pure
yeah it was so pure it was pure it was
it was like but that's the magic you
know and the magic of Cinema
it's like 90 of the labor gives you that
last couple percentage points on the
screen and that's what people don't
understand like it is hard as [__] to
make a bad movie it's really hard to
make a bad movie it's incredibly hard to
make a good movie it's almost impossible
to make a great movie yeah you know yeah
but it's I don't know I love it a blast
for as much [__] as I talk about the
industry I love it like like I love the
job I love the creativity I love
storytelling I love directing and now I
love it for the right reasons okay
versus like oh I had a bad childhood I
need people to blow smoke up Mass so I
feel better about myself because I'm a
[__] director I'm so past that now
dude you know like let's just bleed on
each other and find something real okay
[__] it you're one of a kind dude
seriously thank you bro I ain't gonna
[__] but but thank you this is this
is awesome I love you man love you homie
[Music]
thank you
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already bored Bam
Bam if you want to become part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole wide
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll